[Music]  okay Twitter poll if you could stay one  age forever what would it be what about  the age we are right now seriously  sometimes tuition you can just get out  of the stupid town together  [Music]  [Applause]  you understand she ever talked about  running away check this out  here's the last site she visited  Slenderman he preys on innocent youth I  think this is how he get Katie back  those who hear the three bells toll  accept his invitation when you hear the  first you must close your eyes opening  your eyes only once you've hurt the  third like a virus  some young takes some drugs mad once you  see him see him  [Applause]  [Music]